hey guys what's up this is andrew for
sentences.com so in this video guys i'm
here to make a big update on amc and
from now on i want to let you know that
i will be making more updates on amc and
gme because i know that this is what you
guys want to see and also i will be
moving to panama tomorrow guys i will go
to see gabrielle who is uh trading with
me on discord and we will do some live
trading on youtube together he will be
mostly trading commodities i will be
trading amc gme and different stocks i
hope that this will be interesting for
you guys uh so i just wanted to let you
know that i will not be here tomorrow so
friday with you on discord photo squad
with me uh so i'm sorry about that i
will be back only on monday so this is
the video i want to make just before
going so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so like i said amc i will
be making more updates guys about amc
and gme so let's start daytime frame
guys i'm going to try to be quick we
have some information but let's be
honest we are in a neutral area
in an area where pretty much anything
can happen so let me sum up a bit the
situation
so we were moving strongly lower all
right for the past three months three
four months right since this breakout
that was here which is
a valid breakout okay like i said we've
analyzed this breakout many times it's
not perfect because the consolidation
here was not perfect we like to have
many reactions on low volatility and low
volume so we had the low volume uh we
didn't have the low volatility and with
the reactions as you can see i'm not
touching the trend line which is exactly
what we need to see for this trend line
to be reliable whenever it is broken uh
so here it has been broken we had a nice
move up but then we pulled back which is
kind of i would say usual for a breakout
but then we didn't manage to push higher
despite this bullish engulfing so we got
stuck here
bulls were taking back control all right
until this point and here we got pretty
much rejected basically on the day of
the earnings one day after so what does
it mean it means that bulls were not
strong enough it means that bears are
still you know pushing the price action
lower so of course we have some issues
on the global market so this is of
course related guys it's not an amc
issue it's
just you know bears are taking back
control on the global market i mean they
used to they did take back control and
now it's becoming mutual on spy and
triple q after jerome powell's
announcement yesterday saying that they
will keep a dovish stone on the short
term but somehow uh before the the year
end they will need to increase the rates
i think at least like six rates hikes
more to come all right so it's a bit
hawkish as well so we have different
signals coming from the global market
i'm gonna hear focus on amc because the
global market is not giving us much
information only that we are still in
the mutual area and that pretty much
anything can happen so like i said
bulldog managed to take back
some major levels around 21 24 27 that
we wanted to see
we didn't see it we are now moving
sideways plus we had this breakout guys
below 14.5
i'm not sure i made a video about that
but i of course communicated about this
on my discord this is of course not good
this is a victory of bears that for the
first time managed to get the price
action closing below 14.5
what happened the next day was of course
a bearish move but best didn't reach the
target what was the target guys it's
just the previous support so here 12 is
the obvious support so we are really in
a neutral situation on the short term
because bears managed to push the price
action below 14.5 we had a second close
confirming this breakout is valid once
again this breakout happened on low
volume so whenever you have a breakout
that is happening on low volume guys
just remember that it's not very
reliable that pretty much usually you
have a follow-up but uh it's not strong
and this is the reason why here bulls
managed to take back uh control on the
very short term and push the price
action above the 14.5 level but right
now this 14.5 level is giving us less
information because it has been crossed
from the top to the low and from the
lows to the to the top uh twice in a
matter of four days so this level is not
as strong as it used to be so it gives
us less information so what information
do we have because this is what we're
interesting about and right now the
information we have is that the volume
is still going lower so we don't have a
real direction no one is really leading
and we don't have much information on
the short term we still have uh this i
mean we're moving sideways uh best to
back control boos are facing back bears
are still in control on the medium term
i would say as can be seen then you need
to zoom out if you want more information
and as can be seen on the macd guys the
macd is still going lower but not that
much so whenever the macd starts to go
higher it means that the bullish
momentum is coming back on the medium
term so this is what is happening right
now but that is but we don't have any
clear signal that bulls are taking back
control so
like i said in my previous video what we
are likely to see right now because this
is uh what you guys want to know is
probably like i said yes this is what
i've been saying for the past couple of
months we need time we still need time
it's hard to say if 12 is going to be
touched or not
i would say that bears will push for
that so we might see it this week or
maybe next week it will of course depend
as well on the global market if the
global market starts to be bearish again
i think that 12 is uh inevitable but if
we manage to see some good moves up on
the spy and triple q
we will probably stay in the 14.5 18
range so in this range we are neutral so
like i said my view here is neutral on
the
short medium term i think that basically
we're going to move between 12 and 18
all right we're going to be stuck a bit
in this range if we manage to go above
18 we would find ourselves in the same
situation we were here so we would have
one more chance for bulls to show bears
that they are taking back control that
they are strong that they have some
ammunition that they can use to push the
price action higher so we need to have
this close-up of 18 to get this
opportunity and only then maybe if bulls
are stronger we will reach finally this
trend line i personally don't think
we're going to reach it very soon so
this trend line is right now above
around 24 25 i mean right now it's
around 27 but let's say we reach it in
one month it would be around 25. so this
is i think a reasonable target for bulls
we could put the price action uh towards
this direction maybe if we have some
good news on the global market but if we
don't i mean it's not a big deal because
even if we do we would probably get
rejected then and in the end like i said
guys in my previous update what i think
will happen is that in may we are
trading between 18 and 14 okay so i
don't know if you go first to 12 then
rebound or if you rebound right away and
go to 12 like i said i'm neutral on the
short short term slightly bearish on the
medium term because both didn't manage
to take back control when they had the
opportunity to do so so this is of
course not uh very good news for bulls
but yeah i'm pretty sure we're gonna be
trading in this area guys in may and
then the big question is gonna arrive so
are we gonna be able to break out above
this level and then
finally take back control on the long
run
which would be guys very exciting and we
would then talk again about targets
about what could happen uh we will have
a look of course on the short interest
right now it's not moving much i will
show you that very soon and yeah and if
we go on the downside 12 is not it has
not been tested yet so it's gonna for
sure hold the first time but as you guys
know whatever support is tested multiple
times it becomes weaker so let's see for
now 12 is a strong support
so yeah and also i wanted to let you
know guys once again i'm not sure you
saw that in my gme video we are
launching our nfts so uh there are
crypto bulls and they are representing
the channel guys uh it has been designed
by my step brother and we have a very
solid project behind it it's a trading
project we're going to invest the funds
that we're going to receive we just need
to check if the sec requirements are met
but this product guys is going to be
epic like i said and as you can see we
have different variations that are all
very cool guys so yeah john the discord
join the the twitter that uh the links
are in the description of this video
share it with your friends share it with
your family uh make it grow guys and
come to discord if you want to get white
listed so let's go back to amc the last
thing i wanted to show you guys is the
option market
so here as you can see uh so i have
already downloaded the data uh we have
the march expiry coming in two days guys
so whenever you have an expiry look this
is the gamma okay so i'm not gonna
explain exactly what is the gamma but
basically the bigger it is the more
likely we are to make big moves and when
you approach an expiry the gamma gets
bigger so we are more likely to move
strongly okay this is what it means and
the gamma is 2.2 right now which is
bigger and if we have a look at the uh
max payne so this is uh the the maximum
pain on uh the march 18th expiry we have
a level around 18 i don't know it's
flattish between 17 and 20. so something
between 17 and 20. so this is telling us
that this is the price that option uh
market makers
would like to see for amc on the day of
the expiry so that option holders have
make less money so it doesn't mean it's
gonna go there for sure of course but
we've seen uh with time that this is
happening more often that uh than the
other levels so let's see if we manage
to close around this level this is just
one information the other information we
can have a look at is that right now the
put the put option market is quite
active guys there are a lot of put
options and some of them are in the
money like the 15 put i mean the 15 put
is not in the money since yesterday but
you know all the strikes some of them
has been have been crushed so this is
putting a synthetic long so basically
right now the synthetic shot is
compensated by the synthetic longer so
this is the reason why for now we don't
have anything hot but we still have a
maximum synthetic shot of 20 percent so
this is uh still very bullish and this
is created by the massive number of
shares that we have around the 95 strike
and 145 strike and tomorrow it's the
march 18th expiry and as you guys can
see march is here
okay and i wanted to see
we have a 40 strike right now sorry the
night it's here so we're gonna have the
95 strike that is expiring guys so we're
gonna basically have 38 million shares
less
so
let's see if those shares get those
options get rolled i don't think they're
gonna get rolled right now so i think
that the synthetic shot is gonna drop
the mix maximum synthetic short and then
it's gonna rebuild all right and
whenever it starts to rebuild probably
around may let's see but you know we
have something that is gonna happen in
may like i said guys so this is gonna
give us a lot of information of about
who is able to make this break breakout
happen on the side once again the
breakout will be here guys because we're
gonna have a gigantic triangle all right
this upper band here and on the downside
we're gonna have either 14.5 or 12. like
i said before it doesn't really matter
guys we don't really care if we're at 14
or 12. it's same yes it's two points
we're here talking about 10 20 100
points that might
one day happen guys so two points is of
course nothing uh so let's see if 12 is
going to be the support
of the the lower band of this triangle
or if it's going to be 14.5 i don't know
seriously i don't really know but i
don't
i don't really care i mean it's not
going to change much right 12 or 14. so
let's see let's see what's going to
happen but once again if we see the
option market that is rebuilding
strongly around april may guys this
would be a very very good information
for bulls so that's it for me like i
said guys i will do more updates about
amc and gme and i hope you enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
guys to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new and stay
close to four i'll see you guys